Michelle Turner is back from New York
City with a big surprise that involves
Michael B Jordan and hey sign me up
Oh get in line right behind me and Nancy
O'Dell
this was bananas so cool I was with the
New Jersey native as he surprised his
hometown folks with three different
screenings of Creed two and the reaction
well it was exactly what you would
expect
nice like emotional over those crazy
man's I'm trying not to smile so hard
right now but it's really hard yeah we
cannot wait to see Michael and Creed -
if you can believe it he got even
stronger than he was in the original and
in Black Panther so how does he stay
grounded well you can thank the woman
who watched him grow up his big sister
Jamila it is a little weird when you do
all these like certainly look out for
cameos from Milo Ventimiglia in the film
remember he played sly son in Rocky
Balboa I know that he got sly - come on
- this is us to try to recruit you to an
incredible strong you know honestly
always entertaining good and good and
good care ok
is this true you once got a $40,000
residual check that came to you but
actually wasn't for you yes they'll have
my name on it
and c4 and some zeros they'll quit is
great and then you a little closer to
like nah that's not for you after that I
have to put the B in my name
[Music]